ein klamauk lied spaltet deutschland der
riesen zoff um sommer mega hit layla
geht weiter und es werden die ganz
großen geschütze aufgefahren
sexistisch frauenfeindlich das sagen die
einen kunstfreiheit und spaßkultur die
anderen fest steht nur puff mama leider
im musikvideo übrigens von einem mann
mit blonder perücke dargestellt hier
sehen wir ihn polarisiert und fest steht
auch deutschland verliert den humor
jetzt boykottieren auch die ersten wiesn
wirte den song
[Musik]
was haben diese beiden hier der mit
ihrem ballermann hit layla da nur
angerichtet hitzige diskussion
regelrechter zoff um kunstfreiheit und
eine sexismus debatte die hohe wellen
schlägt dabei ging es diese robin und
schürze nur darum das feiernde am ende
genau das tun
[Musik]
[Applaus]
am ballermann zu grün und spaß zu haben
alles vielleicht kein problem da kann
die puffmutter ruhig so oft rauf und
runter laufen wie sie will hier in
deutschland sieht das anders aus bei
immer mehr veranstaltungen steht der
song auf dem index radiosender spielen
nur noch nachts der grund sexistische
texte frauenfeindliche darbietung die im
grundgesetz verankerte künstlerische
freiheit rückt in den hintergrund zu
recht findet die stellvertretende bild
chefredakteur in yvonne weiß unter dem
deckmantel der kunstfreiheit sollte man
nicht jede geschmacklosigkeit verbreiten
ich finde das lied ist nicht nur frauen
verachten sondern es vermittelt den
kindern auch ein falsches frauenbild
zumal es auch prostitution feiert und
ich stelle mir vor ich bin mit meinen
kindern auf einem volksfest und dieses
lied kommt und meine tochter fragt mich
mama was ist ein puff was bedeutet geil
und was ist eine putz mama ist die so
lieb wie du ich habe kein problem meinen
kindern zu erklären dass prostitution
bedeutet aber wie soll ich denen
erklären dass ein ganzes partyzelt
fröhlich singt und klatscht wenn es um
die ausbeutung von frauen geht das sieht
comedian matze knop etwas anders er
findet die ganze diskussion völlig
überzogen ganz ehrlich wir reden über
ein lied wo man zu feiert und ich
erinnere ich gehe mal so ein paar jahre
zurück ja wir kennen die zehn nackte
friseusen wir kennen noch claudia hat
ein schäferhund zeig doch mal die möpse
von meinem sehr geschätzten kollegen
mickey krause ich hab mal raus klaus und
klaus haben im jahre 2000 gesungen oder
2001 ich brauche nicht vater mutter
bruder ich will ich will ein
schneeweißes luder die ist schöner
blonder fester denn sie ist eine
krankenschwester ja freunde wo ist wo
ist denn und ich weiß auch gar nicht ob
die eltern auf dem volksfest ihren
kindern erklären
ich glaube es ist eher umgekehrt das ist
ein mama das kenne ich alle schon von
you von haftbefehl von kapitel ra du
musst doch noch einmal dass es das macht
sich nicht unbedingt besser aber du
musst noch einmal tief durch scrollen
also ganz ehrlich ich hab ich habe nur
leider gehört ich wüsste den text gar
nicht wenn da nicht so ein riesen
aufriss gemacht wir haben in diesem land
doch andere probleme und auch auf
mallorca sind gerade die eltern anderer
meinung
ich glaube fünfziger weiß nun wirklich
den boss boss über wasser profiserie
leider ist alle drei kinder rennen durch
die bude hüpfen durch die gute und
singen den ganzen tag live also die
kinder hören vielleicht aber
verarbeiten es bestimmt damit dafür zu
klein sein die eltern müssen ja schon
auch ihrer verantwortung bewusst sein
und ich denke es gibt sehr viele lieder
die nicht ganz jugendfrei sind da ist
das ja nicht auf ein sechstel der puff
gehört zum leben dazu eine diskussion
die die gemüter erhitzt doch vielleicht
bleibt der erste ballermann song der es
auf platz eins der deutschen charts
geschafft hat am ende nur eines ein
ballermann song
si
jetzt haben wir so viel über layla
gesprochen jetzt möchten wir auch mit
leider sprechen genauer gesagt mit dem
musiker patrick schmittinger der leider
nämlich in diesem musikvideo gespielt
hat was sagst du zu dem trubel um deine
kunstfigur
natürlich sehr große überraschung freue
mich wirklich unglaublich für hobby und
schürze die
wirklich ein riesenhit rausgehauen haben
und es auch wirklich statt die haben wir
die sorgen wirklich selbst geschrieben
und ich finde es einfach nur fantastisch
dass der erste gut ankommt wirklich toll
es gibt eine riesen diskussion in
würzburg auf einem volksfest soll der
song ja nicht mehr gespielt werden und
auch auf dem münchner oktoberfest steht
leider jetzt auf der schwarzen liste der
songs als sexistisch und solle demnach
nicht mehr gespielt werden was sagst du
dazu kannst du das nachvollziehen
also ich denke eigentlich dass diese
diskussion wie ich schon gesagt hat jede
presse ist eine presse aber das macht
wirklich überhaupt gar keinen sinn das
ist auch für die weltliga schrieb ich
bin ja selbst musik machen
oder auch in die düsseldorfer rheinische
riesen in hamburg und wendy dio leute
uns stehen die ganze zeit leider leider
dann ist es für die bands auch wirklich
richtig schwierig da eine stimmung ins
zelt reinzubekommen lass dir den song
kurz spielen dann muss ja nicht den
ganzen tag spielen und dann sind die
leute zufrieden dass die diskussion ist
meiner meinung nach wirklich übertrieben
aber man darf auch nicht vergessen
die würzburger kiliani war noch nicht so
oft in den schlagzeilen die letzten tage
und auch bilder von feiernden leuten
dort also das ist natürlich für würzburg
auch presse
dass auf jeden fall aber hättest du
während der dreharbeiten je daran
gedacht dass solch eine diskussion
daraus entstehen könnte oder vielleicht
bedenken
eigentlich war auch gar nicht es war
überhaupt über überhaupt nicht
frauenverachtend gemeint das sind
tatsächlich die klamotten von meiner
freundin die hat mir auch die nägel
gemacht alles eigentlich alle frauen die
ich kenne die finden das total super ich
glaube dass diese diskussion also es ist
ja wie so oft dass diese genderfragen
das kommt ja meistens gar noch nicht nur
von den frauen sollen das ist ja dann
von den männern an angefangen und sie
die frauen einfach nur dass das macht ja
auch kurz wegen sowas
also niemals hätten wir gedacht dass es
solche wellen schlägt also ich kann doch
nicht verstehen seine freundin hat ihr
also tatsächlich die nägel lackiert und
auch noch was kleid für den videodreh
geliehen demnach findet sich selbst gar
nicht so schlimm oder
eine kalt weil also wirklich ich kenne
auch niemanden jetzt sagen dieser text
ist jetzt irgendwie schlimm
wenn die kinder das singen also ganz
ehrlich da gibt es kinder die erzählen
bitte da jetzt einfach was sonst gericht
und wenn man dann auch mal texte
anschaut von anderen künstlern dann ist
es aber schon wirklich sehr viel
schlimmer und ich sag mal jetzt ist die
leider verboten aber auf dem volksfest
kann man ja immer noch die wo sie
anrufen 38 16 8 ist sich schon
30 jahre erreicht war und bei leider
machen jetzt so auch wissen
nehmen wir vielleicht heute in der
gesellschaft vieles zu ernst oder
sollten wir einfach ein bisschen
lockerer damit umgehen und einfach spaß
haben
es ist absolut einfach nur ein partysong
nicht mehr und nicht weniger und die
leute sollen dazu feiert die sollen
stimmungen und
richtig was in den letzten jahren nicht
geht wieder mal ins bett geht und
zusammensein feiern und das ist alles
und free leider
vielen dank patrick schmittinger für das
gespräch und das haben wir vor der
sendung aufgezeichnet